[Music]
welcome back to our democratic debate
special before she became United States
senator Elizabeth Warren was a professor
at Harvard Law School very impressive
she was the first tenured professor of
color you'll remember at Harvard Law
School
so she's a researcher she's got an
academic mind it's not surprising she's
been able to discover countless new
forms of racism permeating American life
kinds you've never heard of before she
listed them last night during the debate
listen we need to call out white
supremacy for what it is domestic
terrorism country now where the
president is advancing environmental
racism economic racism criminal justice
racism healthcare racism well she's a
lot of fun the question is what is she
talking about what is health care racism
for example what is environmental racism
we're trying to be open-minded here but
huh we're gonna need some help figuring
out what those even are Bob Woodson is
the founder of the Woodson Center and he
joins us that mr. Woodson thank you very
much for things they do here again I'm
chucker so you've been in and around
politics in the civil rights world for
you know more than 50 years
what is healthcare racism do you have
any idea I have no idea but as a veteran
of the Civil Rights Movement I find I
find her comments insulting
condescending and patronizing it also
acts as a barrier for the exploration of
real solutions that exist for peak
places like Baltimore in low-income
blacks and and I think that for her
continuing to harp on it is really
harmful to any kind of discussion but it
also conceals the kind of real problems
that exist as a veteran of the movement
I remember back in the 60s
I left that movement because many of the
blacks who suffered and sacrificed most
did not benefit from the change dr. King
said what good does it do to have the
right to eat in a restaurant if you
don't have the means to exercise it but
middle income blacks used the
demographics and of the the behavior of
low-income blacks
as debate and the switch came when the
money arrived and that's why the biggest
problem in in black America today isn't
between whites and blacks it's internal
and Elizabeth Warren and people who
continue to emphasize the external enemy
are preaching a false solution black
America's destiny has never been
determined by what white people do I do
not do and but yet but that's what the
we are left with and so what I think
that it reflects attention away from the
real problems and that is the people who
are supposed to be serving those
communities racism is not the most
informal problem it's a problem the real
problem is is the kind of betrayal by
the leaders of these cities in the last
50 years the urban communities where you
have the highest crime the most drug
infested have been run by liberal black
Democrats for 50 years and the question
is and and we've spent 22 trillion
dollars in these places and yet the
problems are getting worse in Forsyth
County Tucker in 1914 the Klan drove a
thousand blacks out in Washington DC
20,000 blacks in the last 20 years have
been driven out by gentrification but
you don't see these leaders addressing
issues economic issues like that is
because they can dodge they can they can
they can avoid confronting those issues
because they use race as a shield
racism I've noticed people could all go
to Europe tomorrow and the conditions of
the inner city would not change and not
all blacks are suffering equally there
are three zip codes in Prince George's
County with a median income for black
families is a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars there are three times
richer than most White's if racism was a
pervasive problem then why are not all
black suffering equally and so I think
it's time to stop this preoccupation
with race and recalibrate and come
together to adjust the problems of low
income Pete
of all races and because answers exist
Jack your your craziest man for saying
that you're a courageous man for saying
that I guess what are they going to say
to you but but most people can't say
what you said and certainly can't say it
as clearly and insightfully as you just
did and we're between the traders they
really are and they need to be called
out for it but there are solutions Jack
Kemp exemplified that student Goldsmith
dick Reardon the first mayor of
so answers exist and we just need to
pursue them but we can't do it as long
as we stay stuck on the race race
grievance issue well of course it just
divides people but Elizabeth Warren
benefits in the short term she got
tenure out of it too so obviously she
sees an upside great to see you tonight
thank you very much and thank you Tucker